with self-consciousness then we have
therefore entered the native realm of
truth we have now to see how the shape
of self-consciousness first makes its
appearance if we consider this new shape
of knowing the knowing of itself in
relation to that which preceded that is
the knowing of an other then we see that
though this other has indeed vanished
its moments have at the same time no
less been preserved and the loss
consists in this that here they are
present as they are in themselves the
mere being of what is merely meant the
singleness and the universality opposed
to it of perception as also the empty
inner being of the understanding these
are no longer essences but our moments
of self consciousness that is
abstractions or distinctions which are
at the switch at the same time have no
reality for consciousness itself and are
purely vanishing essences thus it seems
that only the principle moment itself
has been lost that is the simple
self-subsistent existence for
consciousness but in point of fact self
consciousness is the reflection out of
the being of the world of sense and
perception and is essentially the return
from other nests as self consciousness
it is movement but since what it
distinguishes from itself is only itself
as itself the difference as an other 'no
Simmi d utley superseded for it the
difference is not and it self
consciousness is only the motionless
tautology of i am i but sense for it the
difference does not have the form of
being it is not self consciousness
hence other nests is for it in the form
of a being or as a distinct moment but
there is also for consciousness the
unity of itself with this difference as
a second distinct moment with that first
moment self-consciousness is in the form
of consciousness and the whole expanse
of the sensuous world is per
serve for it but at the same time only
as connected with the second moment the
unity of self consciousness with itself
and hence the sensuous world is for it
an enduring existence which however is
only appearance or a difference which in
itself is no difference the antithesis
of its appearance and its truth has
however for its essence only the truth
that is the unity of self consciousness
with itself this unity must become
essential to self consciousness that is
self consciousness is desire in general
consciousness as self consciousness
henceforth has a double object one is
the immediate object that have sent
certainty and perception which however
for self consciousness has the character
of a negative and the second that is
itself which is the true essence and is
present in the first instance only as
opposed to the first object in this
sphere self-consciousness exhibits
itself as the movement in which this
antithesis is removed and the identity
of itself with itself becomes explicit
for it
in section 167 we're going to get
introduced to a new term now a very
important term particularly for
self-consciousness but running
throughout the rest of the phenomenology
something that has been agitating behind
the scenes the entire time but which we
haven't somatically formulated and that
term is desire what you're going to
notice I don't have on the chalkboard
quite yet that might actually provoke a
little desire on your part to see desire
there there's a lot of jokes we could
probably make now that Hegel's expense
but using Hegel's terminology but we
want to see how desire actually develops
it develops naturally he says in this
investigation into what
self-consciousness is as a matter of
fact he begins this paragraph by saying
with self-consciousness we've entered
the night the native realm of truth so
we're making a new progress into truth
as something that is grasped
systematically in relation to the
subject that's why it's
self-consciousness is so important let
me go dominic says we have known to see
how the shape of self-consciousness the
gestalt right a new new form a new shape
of consciousness precisely
self-consciousness how does it make its
appearance on the scene so its
appearance on the scene is going to
involve as we're going to see more and
more and more in the the paragraphs that
are going to follow this not just
concept but experience or reality of
desire of bagheera in German which also
can be translated as hunger but desire
works better than that this is something
that has captivated readers of Hegel
since then as a matter of fact there
there's quite a few readers of Hegel who
I think of have perhaps given us too
much importance who have focused almost
exclusively on that there are certain
people you could fault with with that
sort of reading but it is quite
important so we want to see how it
develops and it's going to develop out
this reflection or at least it's going
to develop phenomenologically out of
this reflection on the relationship
between the previous stages that we have
encountered so far in the last three
sections of consciousness these these
three movements right and the new self
conscious self consciousness but not
completely self conscious yet that is
arriving on the scene has something not
fundamentally new but something that's
been going on behind all of that that
we're now going to make explicit so
let's see how he frames that some of
this we're gonna see has to be changed
as we go through it he says we want to
consider this new shape of knowing right
knowing of itself what does that mean
knowing of itself well as a matter of
fact for Hegel you know so I got this
IMI thing here this is gonna be a
cul-de-sac we're gonna get rid of this
in just a minute he's not lapsing into
the you know some people want to
correlate Hegel with you know Vedic
philosophy or things like that where
there's kind of a philosophy identity
going on Hegel isn't doesn't deal with
self-consciousness in that way he's
going to eliminate that but what do we
then have this in relation to he says in
relation to that which preceded that is
the knowing of an other you notice I've
got the other here in all caps why
because in this section this is going to
take it on some some very important
tenor right some very important weight
you know a lot of what people focus on
in Hegel tends to be the dialectic
between self and other where others is
understood as an other self right
another human being another
self-consciousness we're going to get to
that don't worry
that's coming up very soon but here the
other means the other sensibilities so
if it is another person it's another
person insofar as I perceive them
insofar as I cannae them under a concept
it's the external world like I put here
world of sensibility the world that I
can perceive the world that is in part
the world of experience although
experience is not totally subsumed by
that you could say that in a way Hegel
is non conscious in that he doesn't
think that you know the the realm of
perception exhausts the realm of
experience that experience also happens
in terms of the self the self
consciousness with an intern allottee
and a reflexivity that's involved so
let's go out he says if we consider it
in relation to that which preceded the
knowing about other we see that that
though this other is in the advantage
its moments have been preserved so we
have the the three previous sections
this is a sense certainty this is
perception
this is force in the understanding they
have been preserved they have been kept
within the you know the kind of the
consciousness which is going to be part
of the self consciousness again says the
loss consists in this here they are
present as they are in themselves now
that sounds kind of interesting doesn't
it the the loss is precisely that they
are in themselves which means that they
don't have what self consciousness does
whatever meaning whatever sort of
referentiality they have is really going
to be coming from self consciousness and
the consciousness that's that's giving
them that is you know you're going to be
part of self consciousness so they are
preserved these are things that happen
these are processes that we're going
through we're not just throwing you know
we're not just cutting out the first
part of the book and saying alright we
begin here with with paragraph 165
throughout everything before that now
we're going to keep that stuff but we're
gonna reconsider our relationship to it
so he says here we go
the loss consistent that's they are
present as they are in themselves the
mere being out of what is merely meant
so the mere being is the other in that
case and the mean
the intending the mining right that we
do by sort of you know taking in the
pure sensible where before we bring
language and concepts to it that's the
kind of knowing that's going on same
thing with the perceiving singleness or
a universality we saw that dialectic
play itself out in perception or the
thing in its quality is right the thing
is a single thing but it's also a
universal thing the qualities are single
things but also okay we remember all
that right force in the understanding a
little bit more going on there a little
bit more complex stuff Hegel just talks
about here empty inner being why does he
talk about empty inner being when it
could be talking about force or law or
world cuz that's where we kept on ending
up right each time we would work out the
dialectic and we try to figure out well
what is the inner meaning of force and
then it turned out that that was the
object the other for understanding and
so what is going on in all of this is
that an other is beating know right so
for instance if it's a book I am knowing
this book as something sensible I bring
it together under a sort of singleness
or a universality book this book I might
go into further you know structures or
something like that book dumb you know
all these sorts of things that we
subsume under laws in any case this is
something other than me this is external
to me I am taking it in the book exists
for me the book has an in itself being
but it's being is also for me I am NOT
for the book unless the book is reading
me you know Allah Augustine who says
that about certain books right now Hegel
goes on and he says all these things are
moments of self-consciousness before
they were moments of consciousness right
it was consciousness that was
understanding all this but it was really
self-consciousness because we were the
ones following along with it seeing that
this is somehow supposed to apply to us
now this is finally becoming explicit
these are NZ says abstractions for self
consciousness they are distinctions that
aren't really distinctions they are
vanishing essences to use another word
that he likes purely vanishing essences
so he says thus it seems that only the
principle moment itself has been lost
the simple self-subsistent existence for
consciousness that which would have
substantiality what we've been looking
for all this time and what we're going
to continue looking for as well so he
goes only says in point of fact self
consciousness is the reflection out of
the being of the world of sense and
perception this over here it is the
world of sense and perception when we
start thinking about it as a totality
right when it's not just this book but
this book against this chalkboard as a
set of objects together this jacket and
this high whatever we want along with it
you know self-consciousness this is
gonna some rather surgery in but that's
cuz Sarge is influenced by Hegel self
consciousness is kind of a hole in the
world in the homogeneity or the totality
of what is you have self consciousness
as a reflection out of that or as a
return from Altera from other nasaan
from on there's be the honor design you
know other being you know in this so he
says in point of fact self consciousness
is the reflection out of the being of
the world of sense and perception is
essentially the return from others the
return to itself from the other nests
that has consciousness it is knowing it
is engaged with it is returning to
itself so he goes on he says and self
consciousness it is movement it is some
sort of process of developing or you
know of changing and so how is this
gonna play itself out says what
distinguishes it from itself what
distinguishes from itself is only itself
as itself so then the differences in
other nests is immediately superseded
for it now immediately superseded
remember when there's a median see not
so good in the Hegelian thing that's a
sort of hallmark that there's gonna be
more going on here
so immediately superseded for he says
the difference is done and
self-consciousness becomes the
motionless totality of IMI so what we're
talking about here yes
how does self-consciousness know itself
or relate itself to itself they could do
it in a what he calls at want illogical
way tautology is where you're literally
saying the same thing you know you're
IMI that's a great example bachelor is
an unmarried male you're just saying the
same thing one plus one equals two right
now
this is tempting to fall into but this
is not really self-consciousness from a
Gallion perspective it may be something
that gets you know recuperated as a
moment of self-consciousness right now
we're actually engaged in the process of
superseding it or leaving it behind but
there can't be all that's going on
self-consciousness in order to be
self-consciousness must be an engagement
not only with itself but also with other
Nisour as we you know like to say in
philosophy Altair anyone other word for
other nuts right how is that gonna
happen then this is where we're going to
get to desire so he goes on and he says
the tautology I am I sense for it the
difference does not have the form of
being it is not self-consciousness this
is not self-consciousness because it
doesn't have any substantiality why
because it lacks any sort of content
that would need to guilt from
self-consciousness or conscious
is engagement with the world it's as if
you can't have one side without having
the other side you can't have a world
all by itself without there being
consciousness to take in that world of
consciousness for whom that is a world
you also can't have self consciousness
as knowing itself without having
consciousness of the world against which
it can contrast itself against which it
can return or reflect itself right from
which so he says other Ness it is for it
in the form of a being or a distinct
moment but there's also the four
consciousness the unity of itself with
this difference as a second distinct
moment this is very important
self-consciousness I've drawn it like
this right where there's self
consciousness and consciousness but
really what we should be saying is
consciousness itself is subsumed in the
self consciousness and self
consciousness as consciousness knows and
other the other stands over and against
it it presents it with something that is
not consciousness or self-consciousness
but which consciousness can know which
it can engage with right that is what
he's calling the first moment here so he
says other news for it in the form of a
being or a distinct moment there's also
for consciousness the unity of itself
with this difference so you might say it
like this
the relation to the other of self
consciousness right is also part of self
consciousness self consciousness is
aware however dimly of itself as
grasping what is not it so this is part
of what makes conscious beings different
from pieces of chalk the piece of track
engages
externally with things the piece of
chalk is for me and is for you and is in
a number of different ways we have the
visual image of it a perception where
you have a linguistic thing piece of
chalk we have concepts we have you know
even ways of understanding how the
material world works through the
understanding all we also have it beyond
that the meaning of the trunk for me and
for you it's something we can draw on
the chalkboard with by that time we're
over here in self-consciousness we're no
longer just concerned with sensibility
right or the concept of the thing we
need give it meaning we give it a kind
of place in our collective or inter
subjective self-consciousness very
important so when he's talking about
these two moments this is the first
moment and this is the second moment he
goes on a little bit more and he says
here we go
with that first moment
self-consciousness is in the form of
consciousness right we're conscious of
the other we're not thinking about
ourselves in that first moment as that
which is other to the other or that for
which the other is other but then we
have this second he says in this first
moment self-consciousness is in the form
of consciousness the whole expanse of
the sensuous world right so here we go
there is the first moment this totality
of the sensuous world that we take in
that is what we're constantly engaged
with and experiencing and orienting
ourselves in relation to and yet that's
not where we stop he says there we go
the sensuous world is for it an enduring
existence which however is only
appearance or a difference which in
itself is no difference
this antithesis of its appearance and
it's truth however for its essence and
for its essence only the truth that is
the unity of self-consciousness with
itself so the meaning the significance
of the world its substantiality so to
speak
and something for consciousness lies
within the scope of self-consciousness
it is part of its orbit part of the way
self-consciousness relates itself to
itself not like this not by turning into
a monad or some well yeah if it was lion
its you Timon and the why you didn't see
them on reflects on the whole universe
right so that would work but I mean some
sort of compressed all by itself
solipsism that's not Hegelian this is a
Gallic right so he goes around he says
this this unity must become essential to
self consciousness what does that mean
then it has not yet become essential to
self consciousness this unity it is
something that should be there or will
be in there but it is not yet there we
might all you know if we want to jump
ahead say that we want it to be there
right and why am I kind of smiling about
this we want it to be there because in
the next couple lines what's he gonna
talk about there we go desire I know
that the board's getting a little messy
but you see the word right desire
Bagheera de he says self-consciousness
is desire in general so consciousness
and self-consciousness he says has a
double object one is the immediate
object the have sense certainty and
perception but for self consciousness we
realize that it's not quite so important
self-consciousness is really interested
in itself and it gives that things out
there that it does desire insofar as
those bear upon itself desire is
something that self consciousness has
for itself for the world for in many
respects more than it can actually say
because we're gonna see that the entire
you know rest of self certainty under
the self-consciousness is gonna be
trying to figure out what does desire
really desire so he says the second
object
or for self consciousness is itself the
true essence present in the first
instance only as opposed to the first
object see that it says in this fear
self-consciousness is the movement in
which this antithesis or this opposition
better put it is overcome but the
opposition is not yet overcome that's
why we still have desire at this point
when all opposition's have been overcome
then we won't actually have to talk
about desire but when is that actually
going to happen
oh you know around paragraph eight
hundred innate depth oh there you have
whatever we're going to be driven as as
following self consciousness out driven
down the paths of desire that historical
consciousnesses have themselves played
out over the course of history that's
where we are going with all of this
you